[Music]
when i was a child at the edge of the
galaxy
i heard stories about a man who could
forecast the future
but the story remained dark to me until
many years later
until it became my story
until it became the only story
you're familiar with my work psycho
history every mathematician has read
your theory it's not a theory
it's the future of mankind expressed in
numbers
and the empire won't like the future i
predict
history is littered with charlatans and
false messiahs
we should kill them
we can murder the man but what about the
movement brother
martyrs tend to have a long half-life
his math was right the empire is dying
wars will be endless
thousand worlds reduced to cinders
change is frightening
especially to those in power
but we can soften the fall
so what's the plan
many years from now
if humanity is to climb from the ashes
the coming generations will need the
knowledge to build upon a foundation
we must preserve only the most essential
pieces of civilization
deciding what is remembered
what is forgotten
we are now staring down a barrel
of a crisis
this is the plan
i'm not turning around now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you